ce vendredi sera marquée par la journée
nationale des droits de l'enfant à cette
occasion l'assemblée nationale a
approuvé dès aujourd'hui à l'unanimité
l'institution d'un médiateur des enfants
qui sera chargée de recueillir toutes
réclamations et d'enregistrer des
problèmes concernant les droits des
enfants
alors avec nous pour en débattre jean
pierre rosenczveig président du tribunal
pour enfants de bobigny bonsoir
alors qu'elle va être exactement le rôle
de ce médiateur pour enfants oui il en
train de se dessiner la loi est pas
notamment voté mais l'idée est en france
comme dans beaucoup de pays étrangers
dans tous les pays d'europe en espagne
en belgique d'offrir un organisme public
qui soit l'interface entre les enfants
qui viennent la société enfants jusqu'à
18 ans et puis les administrations et de
régler ensemble de problèmes individuels
ou collectifs parce que les médiateurs
actuellement pour prenait pas
suffisamment en compte les draps les
enfants peut-être pas suffisamment ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'il n'est pas facile
à saisir puisqu'il faut passer par un
député
hélas la novation importante c'est que
les enfants pourront saisir directement
le médiateur par lettre simple par une
démarche très simple à partir de quel
âge dès qu'elle le pourront dès qu'il a
fait qu'ils le pourront dès qu'ils
sentiront et qu'ils ressentiront un
problème qui pourront l'esprit mais bon
c'est un classique soit estime que c'est
autour de 8 9 10 ans mais l'expérience
des monts forage ou alors c'est demain à
journées nationales des droits de
l'enfant est ce que les droits des
enfants sont respectés en france ou
alors est-ce qu'il ya encore de grosses
lacunes dans sa fin de cuisson qui sont
plus respectés en france que dans
d'autres pays du monde c'est clair la
loi est relativement bonne la pratique
est relativement bonne maintenant on
encore bien colloque à bobigny il ya une
semaine avec 400 professionnels pour
démontrer qu'elle est au nombre
extraordinaire et notamment les enfants
sont les principales victimes de la
paupérisation de la pauvreté et des
difficultés d'insertion nation de
famille en france
dupuis grèce des droits formels qui ne
sont pas reconnus par exemple les
enfants n'ont quasiment pas le droit
d'être entendu en justice mais possible
séparation ils peuvent pas s'associer
facilement fabriquer et des petits
problèmes
il ya beaucoup d'enfants qui sont en
souffrance et puis il ya d'autres petits
problèmes qui ferait toiletté c'est dire
lequel
le sort des enfants et des droits matin
là on évoque lillois et vous sortez
justement un jeu de l'oie l eau nièce
comment vous est venue l'idée
de quoi savoir ce geste années de
brouille l'anecdote c'est qu'avec du
moins un jour ma fille m'a demandé mon
autorisation pour obtenir une carte
d'identité nationale j'étais assez
choqué qu'il faille peu comme parent je
doive donner d'autorisation à ma fille
pour prouver qu'elle était puis aussi
parce que comme professionnel j'ai
constaté que les enfants et les parents
étaient totalement perdus dans les
règles du jeu on leur fait les reproches
ne par exemple d'euros cédé un ensemble
de choses
ils savent pas ce que c'est que le recel
ils connaissent pas les règles du jeu
social
alors on leur dira on dit faut le
rappeler la loi mais comme on l'aura
jamais apprises et qui pourra leur
apprendre la loi sinon les parents sinon
les enseignants sinon les pédagogues
donc on s'est dit que ça serait faire un
coup double que de prendre une démarche
un peu ludique ou ensemble les adultes
et les adolescents pourraient parler la
loi autour d'un jeu effectivement on se
produit sans questions sur le droit de
la famille droit scolaire la vie
quotidien les questions qu'on se pose
tous les jours la citoyenneté les
questions très simples alors
humoristiquement ya un petit exemple je
vais vous tester réviser
alors là lorsque des parents divorcent
le mineur peut-il donner son avis sur le
sort qui lui est destinée non sans trop
jeune âge ne lui permet pas d'avoir un
discernement suffisant oui la loi oblige
le juge et entendre le mineur de 13 ans
je lui demande
ben là c'est pour revenir sur un
quiproquo d'embauché beaucoup de gens
pour les gens sont convaincus qu'elle
est actuellement l'enfant a le droit
d'être entendu en justice s'ils le
demandent non il peut demander à être
entendue mais le juge n'a pas
l'obligation de l'entendre il faut
rappeler la loi aux gens les règles du
jeu social parce que sinon ils sont
perdus donc on a essayé de le faire la
scène qui sont à fait sérieuse et des
questions qui sont plus ou maurice trick
parce qu'il faut aussi qu'on s'amuse et
je pense qu'on peut parler la loi et
c'est le rôle des professionnels que
nous sommes agissent travaux cas on est
parti à quelques-uns et on se retrouve
une vingtaine d'institutions publiques
et privées autour de ce jeu cette
démarche qui est sous forme d'une boîte
de jeu mais qui demain aura des
déclinaisons dans les écoles peut-être à
la division à travers des émissions à
travers 10 cd rom etc
notre idée c'est qu'il faut on aide les
gens à connaître à connaître pardon les
règles du jeu social bien si on veut
leur si on veut déjà dire pour voir
leur permet de se socialiser se fait pas
prendre les lois mais peut-être aussi
les devoirs
monsieur on passe notre tendance et dans
ce jeu a rappelé un ensemble de règles
du jeu par exemple on n'a pas le droit
d'accepter n'importe quoi n'importe qui
on n'a pas le droit de faire du bruit à
n'importe quel moment on doit respecter
son prochain s'ils sont même respecter
lorsqu'on fait quelque chose on peut
engager sa responsabilité bien sûr tous
les droits ne rime pas avec les devoirs
par exemple droit d'être respecté dans
son corps le droit d'avoir à manger
d'avoir un toit dégagé par aucun devoir
mais la plupart des droits de la société
sont engagés aussi parlé de voir les
iphones jeu est très ludique pour les
petits mais je dirais presque surtout
par les dents revêtement il est sous
prétexte d'apprendre la loi aux jeunes
il a essentiellement destiné à prendre
la loi aux adultes et tous les tests
qu'on a pu faire avec vous ou avec
d'autres autour de cette boîte montre
que les adultes ont beaucoup de choses à
apprendre pour une bonne et simple
raison et c'est le titre d'avoir deux
genoux n'est censé ignorer la loi mais
quand la prends ton c'est la seule
matière qui n'est pas enseignée à
l'école la loi jean pierre rosenberg
merci et ce n'est pas encore noël mais
je pense que ça peut être un cadeau ou
intéressante pour les adolescents qui
étaient aussi pour les plus grands